[Music]
hello welcome to JK news today we are
talking about how guys get with girls
that's right because if you missed this
episode we did another one on catcalling
and inappropriate ways of picking up but
now we want to talk about charisma
corner charisma actual way to pick how
do you pick a girl up okay so recently
I've been seeing this thing about how
like even asking a girl for a date can
come off as aggressive male behavior
oh really depends unwanted I mean like
the actual phrase yeah yeah well I read
this thing where a girl was asking like
hey is it uh is it [ __ ] up that I told
the guy to never talk to me again he
asked me out on a date and in other
women were chiming in and they're like
yeah that's an unwanted sexual advance
that's sexual harassment
come on a stranger or like a friend but
it makes I think now the climate makes
guys even more afraid to just approach
women and and just court them like
regular you know what it is it's like
it's like he should have said hey I'll
show you an unwanted sexual advance is
really important yeah I mean you're
right because there's been times where a
guy has asked me on a date and like a
stranger like they saw me and they're
like hey I think you're really cute
would you want to go out sometime
totally innocent and I'm like oh no I'm
sorry I actually have a boyfriend and
then they start to get hostile what they
like what you're from God that I don't
go well no they should they go like what
I just I'm just asking to hang his
friends like he could come bring your
man [ __ ] I don't I don't want to give
you my number and they're like quiet oh
you're you're lost you know you're lost
then you know like what and I'm like oh
my god like so there's times where girls
even just kidding it kind of brings back
some true some PTSD of like no guys
that's an insecure guy who just mustered
all the strength he has in his entire
body to just to ask you out and then you
crushed his entire castle and now he's
got doesn't know what to do but imagine
if you caught his bluff though you're
like oh yeah you just want to hang out
yeah I'll bring my bar
don't hang out right this actually
happened in Beverly Hills recently when
I was going to get my hair cut a guy
dressed he was like a guard or something
like he was like in a uniform and he's
like let me help you cross the street
and he like crossed the street with me
and I was like thank you and then he's
like yeah so kind of get your number and
I was like oh I'm married and he was
like so I just want to hang you know
what your husband has a problem with
just hanging and I was like I don't want
to be your friend I had so my I have an
ex-girlfriend who was propositioned to
hang by Anton yell yell kid who's no
disease wait who's that who's that he
was in I was like oh god ant will die
using a bunch of [ __ ] no using a ton of
[ __ ] you'd recognize my pleasure news
pitcher he's is he actor he's an actor
and he was he was in him and McLovin
we're trying to hang with her right oh
because cuz she had done this interview
thing with that oh is he the guy with a
SUV that's it yes he was in Star Trek he
played check off in the new Star Trek
movies right and so so so she was
hitting me up and she's like hey they
all want to hang and I told them I have
a boyfriend and that you should come
hang with us and I'm like they don't
want to hang with me so she was
oblivious and they don't want to hang
with you she had no idea yeah because it
happens a lot too it's a young age right
so you don't know what's going on with
all the [ __ ] or how this stuff works or
what guys are trying to go for yeah yeah
and so then a nice like a sane guy comes
up and asked you on a date and you're
already on guard because you're like
that's what's difficult is because guys
have to shoot their shot and learn and
through trial and error that's when they
go that's when they find security and
all that like they don't it's
unfortunate that guys have to practice
by doing because they're all gonna come
off hella insecure at first and some
people react yeah just don't take it
personally yeah yeah and then so like
that's I think that's where it's all
kind of [ __ ] up is because in order
for guys to become men and learn they
have to go through the trial and error
but they also can't treat it like
they're selling cellphones at the mall
here I'm saying yeah that's the [ __ ]
up part
we're like yo yo hey you looking for a
boat okay we're like Hollywood Hollywood
Boulevard and they're trying to sell
their album headphones are you know they
like you like you want to buy it
$5 we're just on the side street please
some spare coochie just sample it for a
sample it's not that method but also I
feel like you shouldn't be like hella
thirsty or like treats on a pedestal
yeah on a pedestal it's like it's like
you've been like a longtime fan you just
been watching there like for like I
don't know how many obsessive Steve just
see you up here and you're like oh what
can I get you I'm like whoa dude chill
please you know I really like you you
know like you want to go on date with me
on my mmm I was like please you're kind
of making me feel really uncomfortable
because it's like wavy so we just want
to suck your feet I don't like that
because it's just like when people
didn't know the nasty [ __ ] I would do
for you I treat you like a princess
clean them toes with my tongue no
grateful the only reason why I don't
like that it's just because I feel like
they don't know me as a person right
right
you have a sex object yeah honestly
Julia you look like you have beautiful
feet I'm gonna say this straight up my
toes are [ __ ] nasty because of cross
country
I had several Tony oh my god Julianne
cute why are you killing all those
boners no innocent but one boner just
went up right there you got three for
monetizing the only fans I'll concise
Julia Child feet Julia caffeine and
profitable thanks a lot you ruined both
this business idea dude would have been
there's a whole like I guess a remedy
that guys are trying to do there's a
pickup community like some of my buddies
actually simple pickup they were doing
this in college where they would just
like talk to girls in different ways
like only using rap lines or they made
it fun and but then there's also a toxic
side of that world to where it's all
about just slaying as many
as possible and I think there's a lot of
in cells that get into it because they
get so sexually frustrated and then
they're like it's kind of like a weird
violent sexual thing toward women yeah
but I have a friend who's actually
entered that world because it was more
like he was tired of being shy and tired
of having nervous energy around women
and then once he's entered it he told me
this whole thing about how that there's
a there's a huge like different I guess
group within the group's you know
there's ones that are like well I just
want to learn how to have good energy
around women and be emotionally
intelligent so I can be a better man for
for my girls it sounds like we're
thinking that see this is where it gets
creepy because you don't know the world
so I think I had the same type of stigma
about all of them being these like
completely weird [ __ ] but I realized
that some of them need to think deeply
about a lot of things because they have
no [ __ ] clue no I know but what I'm
saying is I've met these people I know
you're talking about and I think that it
comes off like they're overthinking it
while they're in the moment I also think
of one of the problems is generalizing
women like women like it when you do
this every woman's [ __ ] completely
different so like one move isn't gonna
work on all women no no cuz you're
thinking about pickup lines right pickup
lines or like if you do this this
strategy is this strategizing that and
that's one school of thought but it's
almost like because I just like when
people treat me like a person like talk
about interest eventually it's about
emotional intelligence yes that's not a
board game you know it's not a board
game right what brings out all of the
resentment in those in sales though um I
was like this other species they're like
why don't all of them want me like what
what's going on that's the problem
it's that they are using a strategy to
draw external validation for themselves
and when that strategy fails to them it
feels like they've failed and that's why
they take it so personally that's why
they can't I get my valide because
you've attacked me
you you've attacked me and my strategy
that I came up with it was supposed to
work it's supposed to look at all -
exactly and it ends there but you know
and honestly
the remedy for that and this is a remedy
for a thousand times is a thousand
things is finding validation internally
rather than externally because it's
absolutely unshakable then yeah it all
comes back down to self love but I think
like the heady part where I think you're
explaining is the whole strategy and
logic aspect of it instead of just
having genuine connections with human
beings right so you're manipulating the
situation making them think that you're
connecting but you really you have this
moded of just numbers [ __ ] a lot of
girls having a lot whatever right or
even just [ __ ] one right but you are
coming out at an angle it's very fake
yeah yeah so um there's different
schools of thought within that community
there's one that's more emotionally
intelligent as just I'm just trying to
connect with you yeah that's great and
develop myself through this mean right
and then there's another who's I think
is like more on the psychopathic side
where for them they have an addiction of
finding validation with women and just
having as many as possible and that
becomes like their badge of honor I
[ __ ] a thousand women this and that
like you know and it's pretty weird
that's weird yeah yeah I actually it's
so a really good friend of mine that I
went to high school with he was exactly
like that and it [ __ ] him up so much
to the point that when he finally
settled down with a girl he would only
date a virgin because he genuinely
believed like all women were [ __ ] so
he was projecting his own hornist yes
yes yeah and also this guy had mommy
issues I don't know like where I don't
know the details of it but I know he
always jokes Oh mommy issues mommy
issues issues with women cuz that's the
first woman that you know but it was
interesting to me that when he settled
down he had to date a virgin because he
was like this she's just out there
[ __ ] anyone everything you know and
things virgins won't cheat and he seemed
like such a normal cool guy though like
he was very popular in high school very
attractive and and like it just I don't
know it blows my mind but all the time
he still thinks like she's doing some
[ __ ] behind his back and I know it's the
it's the mommy issues
you know daddy issues we just be like
you know let me call him papi or
something but mommy issues
be like I want to kill this woman I
think I never developed mommy issues
because I don't respect my mother no
respect no issue really hopeful
I do believe you're not gonna believe
that you you actually have the best
relationship with your mother ever oh I
thought she was completely gone it makes
it funnier though it's like when you
love your mom and you call her a [ __ ]
the context so they're in on the jokes
how do you close to being true it's like
it's like the other night of danger boys
somebody came up to me like tell me a
joke and I was like Bart's face cuz
that's so absurd yeah like Bart is a
beautiful man right I used to call that
full fat as [ __ ] right it's like yeah
that's kind of you know people don't get
that though they might be like and he's
like oh my god you're like kidding music
a lot of people seem to be very literal
these days and I think it just goes back
to being socially and emotionally
intelligent because that is really the
cue of everything or that's the secret
of your confidence yeah yeah when you
love yourself and then you have
confidence sexy yes turn-on to most
people is somebody with confidence
whether you're a guy or a girl if you're
confident it's [ __ ] sexy it's not
overconfident yeah you know what though
- I don't know who kind of brought this
up but win that strategy you know what
they don't tell you in those sales
things on how to pick up girls they
don't say by the way if you come off too
fake she's not gonna [ __ ] like it
they just give you a bulleted list of
here's what you do but they don't tell
you that part and then when it doesn't
work out they're like it's me I'm a
piece of [ __ ] I must wear all women
don't like me they have it out for me
like calm down you are not that special
another woman telling me this
know what's happening again guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]